you were uh a young guy one of the jobs
you had i don't think we ever talked
about this
you were a santa claus in a uh store
right really yes now where now where did
you do that
i just moved to san diego
san diego
you know i always think you just think
perverts take those jobs so they can get
kids on their left we were talking about
that yesterday is there a school or
yeah i mean that whole santa business is
is something else i mean i mean some
guys just that's all they live for is
christmas these older guys are they grow
the beards out it seems like it'd be a
good job though do you get paid a decent
amount not a good job why is it bad well
for me it was i was 23 at the time 24
right thin you know i didn't even i look
like a kid i should have been sitting on
santa's lap
yeah you were barely a man
and i was in san diego i just moved out
from connecticut right into stand up and
i was and i want to check out san diego
first and so my buddy and i worked for
manpower temporary help agency so we had
a lot of like part-time jobs yeah
and
and
they were everything from like cleaning
out warehouses right you know pulling
weeds out of parking lots whatever work
you could grab for the day whatever you
could do and you didn't need a lot you
just need enough to pay you know the
hotel or whatever and so um um we got a
job uh working in santa clauses they
asked for you know for two months
and um i worked in the sears department
store in north uh park in san diego but
you probably say to yourself hey this
beats clearing out a warehouse all i can
do is sit here and just talk to these
kids oh yeah and you're a star here
comes santa claus right you know you got
the beard you got the you have the fact
that yeah
uh we had a little stuffing in there
about as much as 400 fronds you're like
a skinny santa it really was yeah and it
was just like a cotton beard it was so
cheap and they were really cutting so
many corners and and basically it's to
get it's to make money and taking
pictures right right that's where they
make the money in the photo department
and a lot of the kids from tijuana would
come over really and a lot of them were
scared and they would pee on your lap
are you [ __ ] me
but the i think the santa agency knew of
this that would happen so they
scotch-guarded all their clothes so the
pee would just bubble up and roll off
the leg is that true yeah you're not
making this up no no no no you're
telling me they treated the santa claus
outfits with special scotch gardens so
that the pee because they knew they beat
it up and rolled off howard i'm telling
you that they sprayed these suits with
the scotchgard oh my god this is huge uh
this is news
you've just broken news that no one ever